Lambton is getting ready to hit the
campaign trail as a newcomer to politics
the 27 year old is not taking the
conventional route the guy for which I
don't buy or denies weekly runs in my
neighborhood I hope it can keep everyone
healthy because we need to be fit to be
able to cope with the chaos here lam is
running for a district council seat
together with other young protesters
over half of the candidates from the
opposition camp have no political
experience they're also not affiliated
to any political party and most of their
campaigning is coordinated online Lam
used to work in a bank
if the protests had interrupted he'd
still be there for him though it was now
or never to stand up for his beliefs I
realized there are more important things
than money if we lose our freedom
democracy our hometown then it's
meaningless no matter how much you
weren't I would later regret it if I
didn't take a stand that's why I quit my
job some of the candidates are familiar
faces Tommy Chang was among a group of
former students convicted for their
roles in the 2014 umbrella movement now
the 25 year old activist has taken a
step back from the front line to fight
on another battlefield I did plan to
study abroad once I had completed my
community service sentence what happened
to the umbrella movement made me feel
powerless and a failure but those
feelings have been washed away by the
current movement it gives us hope again
we failed to achieve anything five years
ago so this time I am standing up for my
beliefs in a different way
even though I'll call my host a tivo
over 4 million voters will elect
candidates to some 450 seats although
the council is just an advisory body
members are eligible to run for the
committee which picks the city's top
leader
with demonstration still continuing
after almost six months and with no end
in sight the opposition says the poll is
a referendum on their demands elections
become less credible when people are
blocked from standing in them but
democratization has taught us not to
give up any chance to vote street fights
shouldn't be the only way for people to
express their will we aim not only to
win seats but to bring about political
change I would rather lose the election
than lose the movement because lots of
Hong Kong people have sacrificed so much
some have lost their lives some may be
jailed for 10 years but we still have a
long way to go and I hope that people
will keep on pushing for change no
matter how the movement develops it's
unclear whether ballots can eventually
stop the bullets many in Hong Kong hope
they won't have both on Election Day